Gustavo Petro se retracta y baja la
temperatura en su enfrentamiento con la
fiscalía el presidente de Colombia lo
hizo desde Portugal en plena gira
ibérica y tras un llamado de atención de
la Corte Suprema por las drogas acepto
el llamado de la honorable Corte Suprema
de Justicia respeto y respetaré la
autonomía independencia de la fiscalía
general de la nación y todas las ramas
del poder público pero como presidente
de la república no guardaré silencio
frente a estas gravísimas denuncias el
viernes Petro había dicho ser el jefe
del fiscal Francisco Barbosa esto le
causó reprimendas públicas de distintos
sectores criticado por no entender la
separación de poderes el fiscal Barbosa
escogido por el expresidente Iván Duque
fue más allá dijo que sacar a su familia
del país y realizó la siguiente
acusación Petro se cambió el traje de
demócrata y se empieza a poner un traje
de dictador
Petro y Barbosa se han estado
enfrentando durante meses por los planes
de paz total del presidente
la escalada final llegó esta semana
después de que Petro invocando a la
Constitución pidiera información a la
fiscalía lo hizo En referencia a una
investigación periodística de la nueva
prensa y el periodista Gonzalo Guillén
afirmaba que el fiscal delegado de
Barbosa Daniel Hernández habría recibido
información previa de 200 asesinatos que
iban a ser cometidos por el plan del
Golfo el fiscal habría ignorado las
alertas las muertes habrían ocurrido y
habría protegido a los asesinos